every eye forms its own fancy
he who loses money loses much he who
loses a friend loses more
he who loses faith loses all
[Music]
better to be fortunate than rich
when a tweet grows hard it is difficult
to twist
every beginning is weak
[Music]
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
[Music]
a good retreat is better than a bad
stand
[Music]
a man's work praises him
[Music]
continual cheerfulness is a sign of
wisdom
[Music]
god made time
man made haste
[Music]
a good laugh and a good night's sleep
are the best cures in the doctor's book
[Music]
if your messenger is slow go to meet him
a wren in the hand is better than a
crane to be caught
no time for health today
no health for your time tomorrow
[Music]
there's no need to fear the wind if your
haystacks are tied down
[Music]
god's help is nearer than the door
the longest road out is the shortest
road home
there is no luck except where there is
discipline
a little fire that warms is better than
a big fire that burns
[Music]
there are finer fish in the sea than
have ever been caught
[Music]
idleness is a fool's desire
[Music]
every patient is a doctor after he's
been cured
[Music]
better to be a man of character than a
man of means
if you do not sow in the spring you will
not reap in the autumn
it's no use carrying an umbrella if your
shoes have holes in them
[Music]
a trout in the pot is better than a
salmon in the sea
he who comes with a story to you brings
two away from you
a friend's eye is a good mirror
a watched kettle never boils
he who gossips with you will gossip of
you
he is bad who will not take advice but
he is a thousand times worse who takes
all advice
better good manners than good looks
[Music]
where the tongue slips it speaks the
truth
you've got to do your own growing no
matter how tall your grandfather was
forgetting a debt doesn't mean it's paid
need teaches a plan
bricks and mortar make a house but the
laughter of children make a home
the friend that can be bought is not
worth buying
if you dig a grave for others you may
fall into it yourself
instinct is stronger than upbringing
do not resent growing old
many are denied the privilege
never bolt your door with a boiled
carrot
when luck comes it comes by the bucket
full
time is a good storyteller
perseverance is the mother of good luck
patience is a poultice for all wounds
it is not a secret if it is known by
three people
a man loves his sweetheart the most his
wife the best
but his mother the
longest men are like bagpipes no sound
comes from them until they are full
praise the ripe field not the green corn
never burn a penny candle looking for a
half penny
a glutton lives to eat
a wise man eats to live
do not bless a fish till it is landed
a sword a spade and a thought should
never be allowed to rust
he who is bad at offering lodging is
good at showing the road
a constant drip wears a hole in a stone
when the cat is out the mice will dance
not every flatterer is a friend
[Music]
look before you leap
learning is the desire of the wise
[Music]
hope is the physician of misery
[Music]
a constant guest is never welcome
[Music]
character is better than wealth
even black hens lay white eggs
it's not a delay to stop to sharpen the
scythe
beware of the anger of a patient man
[Music]
hindsight is the best insight to
foresight
[Music]
no matter how many rooms you have in
your house you're only able to sleep in
one bed
experience is the comb that life gives
to a bald man
if you are looking for a friend without
a fault
you will be without a friend forever
god's mill may grind slowly
but it grinds finely
[Music]
you'll never plow a field by turning it
over in your mind
[Music]
there's no use boiling your cabbage
twice
sunshine always follows rain
put silk on a goat and it's still a goat
better to spend money like there's no
tomorrow than to spend tonight like
there's no
money may today be better than yesterday
but not as good as tomorrow
what a sober man has in his heart a
drunk man has on his lips
success consists of getting up just one
more time then you fall down
[Music]
climate is what you expect weather is
what you get
in the land of the blind the one-eyed
man is king
[Music]
the innocent and the beautiful have no
enemy but time
we are all in the gutter but some of us
are looking up at the stars
i complained that i had no shoes until i
met a man who had no feet
beautiful young people are acts of
nature
beautiful old people are works of art
the best things in life are the people
we love
the places we have been and the memories
we have made along the way
[Music]
take the world nice and easy
and the world would take you the same
[Music]
don't go broke trying to look rich
[Music]
he who keeps his tongue keeps his
friends
[Music]
a tune is more lasting than the song of
the birds and a word more lasting than
the wealth of the world
two people shorten the road
the more sexual partners a woman has had
the more likely she is to be depressed
[Music]
there is only one thing worse than being
talked about
and that is not being talked about
lie down with dogs and you'll get up
with fleas
a cabin with plenty of food is better
than a castle with none
[Music]
in every land hardness is in the north
softness is in the south
industry is in the east and fire and
inspiration
in the west
you